Leute seid ihr nervös erstes Mal GTA
Luca wie breche ich ein Auto ein wenn
noch irgendjemand altviel hier schreibt
ich schwöre es euch ich ich ich ich beiß
euch alle in den Arsch
ey Leute es ist soweit ich fahre ich
fahre Laser Leute soll ich mich mal
richtig an die Verkehrsinsel hier halten
die Verkehrsinseln ey das wird so lacht
gegen sein Handy gleich sehen wir uns
wollen wir uns direkt Boxen wenn wir uns
sehen
wo du bist ich bin unterwegs zu dir sind
1,7 km denn die dann sehen wir uns genau
wenn die Sonne gleich aufgeht wenn Du
möchtest
ich bin fast da
ja bin auch da wo bist du
ich drehe mich im Kreis Berlin
einsteigen
oder warte ich frag mein Holz
und dann fährst du ihn aber okay aber
komm du musst dich jetzt doch alle
Verkehrsregeln halten okay ab jetzt okay
du hältst jetzt wie bei der Fahrschule
an alle Verkehrsregeln vergessen
deutlich zu schnell deutlich zu schnell
vergessen
[Musik]
so ich trifft jetzt um die Kurve ich
zeige
jetzt mal bisschen hier die CD okay
guck mal
wir sind da wir spielen jetzt mal wie
ein echt okay
wir fahren jetzt mal dem Auto hinterher
schauen wir ob wir irgendwo ein paar
Parkplatz ist komm wir können auch hier
parken oder
nein nein ich bin fast tot hey Luca
können wir Riesenrad fahren
wie geht das denn
laufen komm hin
und dann was muss ich drucken diese
Taste die oben angezeigt wird
du musst nach rechts klicken glaube ich
nach rechts sind die Jahre später
müssen wir uns auch sogar ein paar Date
Sachen unterhalten nein danke ich habe
mich ganz lieb auf jeden Fall nein also
das war das Schlimmste was Du bisher
gemacht
wir schauen uns jetzt immer alles an so
ein bisschen okay
hier gibt's Lobster
hör auf hör auf
ich rasch komplett
ausgehen
weil das vier
hier hat natürlich nicht nur
an Land einige Sachen
[Musik]
wie beispielsweise
die Achterbahn oder das Riesenrad wo wir
gerade gemacht
sondern auch
[Musik]
schneller laufen wenn du die ganze Zeit
X drückst
wo bist du
ja holen
[Gelächter]
hier bin ich
warum machst du das
Digger warum fragst du mich so ab das
ist wie im echten Leben das macht
irgendwie
[Musik]
es ist jetzt nachts das heißt ich würde
sagen wir machen irgendwas was man so
typisch bei nachmachen
[Musik]
wo bist du
Mann ich muss jetzt ganz ganz lange
Kameraden machen das kann man
ein privater Tanz ist gegen die
twitch-richtlinien
man hat bei Sandra Brüste gesehen
ach du scheiße
um
die Sache ist ich würde mir auch gerne
eigentlich mal so einen private Dance
angucken die Leute sagen ich muss ganz
schnell Stream löschen und neu starten
und mein biodie löschen
kann
ich aber Vollbild ihr könnt es an hat
meine Augen beobachten was hier passiert
anscheinend ein paar Sekunden später
[Musik]
gute Frage
oh mein Gott ich lande in der Session
mit Leuten ich war nicht reden ich
dachte die das reden wir da ich bin so
eine heftiges Opfer haben die mich
gehört
Sandra hier sind
Sandra hier sind Leute drin Spanier
Sandra die sagen die ganze let's go geh
mal raus jetzt hier
ich denke gemacht
mit denen
ja die haben so viel Spanisch geredet
ich muss jetzt kurz mal in die Schranken
[Musik]
wir müssen uns noch mal kurz neu finden
Leute dieser Stripclub hat alles
durcheinander gebracht jetzt drücken wir
noch mal auf Start
das ist noch mal statt
ich würde sagen wir fahren erstmal hier
runter
denn ich zeige jetzt mal ganz schöne
Ecke wenn wir jetzt
hier links fahren Sandy
[Musik]
kann man hier den Berg runterfahren
[Applaus]
okay
hier einfach mal aus dem Auto aussteigt
siehst du mein Haus
wie findest du es Sandra
[Musik]